hi there Steve here Steve Kaufman again
to talk about languages as I always do
here and I have a confession to make I
was wrong and stephen krashen
was right I have often said that I
consider the three keys to language
learning success to be the attitude of
the learner the time we spend with the
language and the ability to notice now
it's not something that I came up with
this is something that I had heard at a
conference of the American Association
of teachers of foreign languages and it
was the head of the San Diego State
University language department who said
this and I was very struck by it and I
have repeated it many times
stephen krashen would always say to me
noticing no we don't deliberately notice
we learn subconsciously through enough
compelling comprehensible meaningful
input I have come to the conclusion that
I was wrong and stephen krashen was
right and I think because I think that
the ability to notice is something that
develops naturally it develops naturally
if we get enough input if we expose
ourselves ourselves to the language if
we listen and if we read so I will now
say that the three keys to language
learning success are again the attitude
of the learner you know like the
language want to learn want to be
learning this language confident that we
can do it all of these positive things
that's extremely important the second
thing is the amount of time we spend
with the language in other words not
reading a grammar book in our own
language not necessarily even sitting in
a classroom is it's the time we spent
listening reading speaking engaged with
the language that time and the third
thing is the availability of good
compelling comprehensible meaningful
content and in reflecting on my own
language learning I do bear
in those languages where I was able to
find that content and this means that we
need initially to have beginner content
which again I don't think should be
absolute brain-dead beginner content but
content must like our many stories where
you get into a sort of an intermediate
level of content but there is lots of
repetition and of course because there's
so much repetition the stories can't be
that tremendously compelling but an
initial period you're kind of motivated
to to get a sense of the language to
discover how the structure of that
language how it works and so forth but
very soon you have to get into something
where you are actually interested in the
content stephen krashen claims that this
is stories you know fiction he's a big
believer in fiction personally I'm more
interested in nonfiction and I've said
before that in Chinese the availability
of graded readers on history and
geography were very helpful in terms of
getting me to the next stage where I
could actually read and listen to
content you know authentic documents
from history or books and things of that
nature so finding that content is
extremely important and I think we
should do more language learners to pool
our resources help each other or or even
to create these resources so that native
speakers in a certain language maybe
there should be more people just
recording conversations and maybe we
could have a website where we all put
them up there so that now for example in
Arabic so that I could access natural
conversations in Arabic transcribed or
in Farsi so ah but I think this content
thing is it doesn't matter like I was at
the Montreal long fest and there were
different presentations and on different
techniques chunking and there are some
people who who like to use memorize and
Anki and of course I don't very much I
just stay with link but all of that is
secondary secondary the key thing is the
availability of meaningful content in
the language so that's the third one
attitude then
and the content content is king and I
think that too much effort that there's
all kinds of starter books grammar
explanations there are other
dictionaries Enki's games language
learning games none of that matters in
my opinion what matters is having
suitable content and and graded content
you know can be a bridge to get to where
you can access the authentic content but
I also think natural conversations are a
bridge because typically in
conversations the vocabulary used is
it's more sort of oriented towards
high-frequency words so I would love to
see an explosion of conversations you
know dialogues in different languages
spoken naturally and then transcribe
made available to language learners you
know I had a comment mmm I think it was
here at YouTube if someone said why
would anyone learn Farsi it's a
difficult language and that you know the
verbs show up in different places in the
you know depending on whatever and stuff
I don't know he had a lot of criticism
of Farsi none of that matters if I can
find compelling and interesting content
in Farsi and I'm motivated because
there's Farsi speakers here in Vancouver
and because after all Iran and Persia in
terms of those 80 90 million people
there historically it's been a very
important country you know 2,500 years
ago the Persian Empire was the largest
you know Empire in the world and oh that
is kind of stimulating so things that
affect your motivation and the
availability of good content is much
more important than details of that the
language is too complicated and it's
silly and so every language has its
complications I don't think Farsi is
unique in that regard it doesn't matter
the technique techniques you use don't
really matter except to the extent that
you need to be efficient so in consuming
this compelling and interesting content
you should use techniques that are
efficient like thumbing through a
dictionary
traditional dictionary is not efficient
no sooner do you close the dictionary
then you've forgotten what you looked up
so I don't consider that efficient but
there are things that we can do to make
this you know all important consuming of
reading and listening more efficient
because the more efficient it is the
greater intensity of the the greater the
intensity of the learning but but
ultimately though it's the interest
level in that content the ability to
access it the comprehensibility of it
that's gonna make that input activity so
powerful so I just wanted to say that
and I think we have to try better at
link as well we have a lot of content
there and people can import content they
can import ebooks but we're gonna be out
there looking for partners who can
provide us with whether it be free or
even to sell across link nothing wrong
with paying for something I would rather
pay for content than pay for classroom
time quite frankly because it's the
content that's gonna take us to fluency
so just to summarize I I confess that I
was wrong and once again stephen krashen
was right and he really is the Guru when
it comes to language learning you can do
other stuff you can read the grammar you
can do flashcards you can do all this
other stuff and that's good and if
you're motivated to do it then do it and
it does provide you with you know a
different form of exposure to the
language and and does sort of maybe
stimulate you if you're interested in
those kinds of things but overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly it's your attitude your
the time you'll spend and the
availability of comprehensible
compelling input and of course all three
are interrelated and reinforce each
other there you have it thanks for
listening bye for now
[Music]